millions of years ago the earth looked
very different a huge land mass called
Pangaea covered about a third of our
planet but about 175 million years ago
the earth broke up into continents and
formed the world we know today what if
that had never happened where would your
country be located and how different
would your life be this is what if and
here's what would happen if Pangaea had
never broken apart if Pangaea existed
today in theory you can drive from
California to England since they'd both
be part of the same landmass and
although you may only think of Pangaea
as just another piece of land it would
be much more than that it's played an
integral part in human and animal
evolution if Pangaea had not broken
apart you may not be here today but
let's assume it didn't and that we
survived and evolved to be the people we
are today what would the earth be like
first let's talk about where your
country would be located North America
would be right here Europe would be a
lot closer just to the East Asia would
be up north
by Russia and Antarctica would remain
down south India and Australia would be
further south connected to Antarctica
these countries that used to have hot
climates would now be cold covered with
snow and ice and those wouldn't be the
only environmental changes regions in
the middle of Pangaea would have lush
rainforests along their borders and as
you travel further inland he would
become a desert this would be due to
pangaea's landmass being so large rain
which comes from the ocean
travelled far enough inland leaving
parts of Pangea practically
uninhabitable by humans and other
species and weather up north would be
different to with Russia being much
warmer than it is today but the weather
wouldn't be the only thing that would
change on Pangaea we might have less
diversity of species the species at the
top of the food chain today would most
likely remain there but some of today's
animals would not exist in Pangaea they
wouldn't have the chance to evolve fewer
animals might make it easier to travel
and on this modern version of Pangaea
you'd probably want to do a lot of it
luckily you wouldn't have to go far if
you lived in Florida you'd be right next
to the Caribbean islands Venezuela and
Brazil you could visit all of these in a
single day and if you lived in Nova
Scotia Canada you'd be driving distance
from France England and Germany although
this might sound like fun a lot of
countries would have new neighbors which
could cause some serious issues for some
places like the United States which used
to have oceans on both sides of the
country would now have Africa on its
east coast if these countries didn't get
along things could get ugly how much
easier would it be to start a war in
another country if they were just a
short drive away transporting weapons
people and supplies would all be faster
and cheaper if certain countries were
right next to each other or none of this
would happen and the entire world would
be more unified than ever with all of us
sharing the same land mass maybe we'd
learn to treat each other just a bit
better than what we do now maybe if we
all lived in one country something like
this would happen but we'll leave that
story for another what if
you